All right, we're ready to go. It is, I don't even know what date it is. What is it? 18th of July, 2018, our Zoom call.
We're going to talk a little bit about genetic testing. So it reminds you what we're looking at when we are going to be doing that for you if we have not done that for you.
Also reminder, this too, if we've already got over your 23 and the details, and you want to go over it again, you can do that, just schedule with the office schedule with ads, which you can go over it with you again. She's the one that's going over that now. She's fully certified in it. Ashley's going to be fully certified within the next week or so.
So as Michelle, it is a certification process that there's just literally handful people in the world that are certified. So I feel very blessed to have, you know, three more people in our office that are fully certified to go over genetics when there's literally just, you know, five or six dozen people worldwide that really are certified to do so.
If you want to look at your genetics, if you want to look at something that you maybe forgot or missed, feel free to schedule a time to go over that again.
When we look at genetics, I am sharing my whole screen here because I want to pull up some slides with these are the slides that we go through that will remember on the, when we look at your genetics, there is a whole mess of information on our website.
So if you go to our cottage clinic website, you will see if you look at jeans tell stories here, this link right here.
It brings you to some very basic information about genetics here and then you could go down to cancer genes, the book, which is a series of videos explaining what we're looking at.
With a cancer patient with their genetics. So here's the introduction to the book section one section one, the more videos on the gut and what we're looking at with your genetics.
Cancer diets, energy genes and it just keeps going and going and this is just going to be a endless stream of videos.
So why did I do that in a series of videos instead of in written material because it's easier to show you on a genetic work up on the what we're going to produce for you.
Because you get a copy of that genetic work up just like what you see on this video, you'll get a copy of this, which is about 60 pages of your genes and you could literally go through my videos and look at your printout and learn about your genes and what you need to do and how you could help yourself.
So again, my purpose is try try to empower you to have control.
One of the things that I know that is sometimes easier for us as human beings is that we want to somebody else to solve our problems for us.
And I understand that patients come to our clinic at times that they say here's my disease or here's my problem here you take it. Now I don't have to be responsible anymore and you're responsible to get me better.
Well, a couple of things on that number one, that's not fair. I can't get you better. My purpose in helping you get better and our clinics purpose is to try to seek wisdom and we try to seek wisdom from the Holy Spirit in giving you information to help you.
And then what you do with that information, we have literally had people come to us to our whole program, go home and never use the knife and never do their diet and never do their nutrition.
And I know they have it because they never repurchased any products or we get their knife back and I have a way to look at a person's computer and tell if they how much they've actually used it and it's sad sometimes.
But everybody in the flip side it's not sad. Everybody has a choice to make it. They have to do what they think is right for them.
That is called responsibility and that is called also your power. You don't want to give your power to someone else and I do realize as a human being it's easier to do that.
And to go to the doctor he's going to diagnose my condition and that it's his responsibility to get me better by giving me the right medicine or the right drug or the right therapy and no my problems going to go away.
That is what we've been taught in Western medicine and that is a lie. That's a steal of your power.
Glory that to be in someone else's hands and it usually doesn't end well. So that's not our purpose and I realize that's the that's the perspective that most people are coming from that's what they've been taught their whole life that I'm they're not a doctor so that's not their problem.
So when they go to the doctor it's the doctor's problem to solve their problem and the medical profession is all too eager to take that responsibility because they make a lot of money off of it and they get people dependent upon them and they can keep a person dependent upon a medication their entire life and there's all sorts of reasons.
You usually hinted with evil that they want to do that that's not our purpose and I state that from the very beginning.
Our purpose is to empower you and I realize everybody has a different level of intelligence and a different drive of understanding and not everybody wants to nerd through these videos and listen to them.
Many people want to go just I'm not here to learn everything you just tell me what to do and we will do that and we will give you our best recommendation, but that's all we can do.
There is it's it's often that a person will go through my videos ago hey shouldn't I also be taking procurement because you said on this video this and I have this defect and welcome back and say well that might be a good idea so that's how we want to empower you.
So please take advantage of that if you can I also understand if you don't want to but we give you every tool that I can possibly think of and giving our books away and giving away all this information in these videos and doing the zoom calls every week to try to empower you to not give your power away and I think if you're dealing with something serious.
Yes, right cancer, the more that you could retain that power over your body the better you're going to you're better your outcomes going to be so that's just my belief you could think otherwise, but I think the more you could control your outcome, the better off it's going to be.
So it is that we're trying to constantly look at new ways to try to help people if you've got a hint at my tabs on my when I had my browser open it's basically all research pieces so that that's that's all I do in life and that's what I feel like my purpose is and I'm happy to do it and it's.
It's to help empower more people to take information and make better use of it in their life and hopefully get to the results that they will ultimately knowing that it's all in God's hands and we fall back in the sovereignty of his love for us and his will for us and we can trust that wholeheartedly regardless of what the outcome is going to be.
But I do believe it is our responsibility to seek wisdom and to seek knowledge and to walk therein so it is we're going to talk about personalized medicine and genetics always when we look at genetics understand.
Understand happy genetic control trumps are genes most of the time yes if we have a trisomy 21 situation and we're bored with down syndrome it's really has nothing to do with my diet or chemical exposure etc but if I have a trisomy 21 situation and down syndrome.
So diet and chemical exposure and such is going to make my condition worse so it though epigenetic control trumps the genetic predisposition most of the time it's always epigenetic issues affect our genes what does that mean epigenetic means things that are outside of our genes things that are.
Iron mentally driven that affect our genetics so i've i've talked to people and scientists to say say has nothing to do with our gene that has everything to do with our diet and our environment and everything well if you watch any of my videos and understand the genes you'll understand that is that does he make any sense if I have defects in my detoxification pathways and I'm exposed to chemical toxins.
I have more of a health risk an issue an increase risk of cancer at all sorts of disease then someone who doesn't have the same genetic defects in detoxification pathways it is exposed to the same about or even more toxins than I am so genetics are extremely important and when we deal with cancer patients they're even more important because cancer.
has to do with certain carcinogens in our environment that affect us like this slide all different things epigenetically that are affecting us and something getting inside the cell and causing a replication increase in replication rate.
What's supposed to happen is that we have these genes called tumor suppressor genes that are supposed to kick on in that case of sensing rapid replication and they should cause a death of that cell or increase apoptotic rate of that cell in the or the cells that we're talking about if I have defects in those tumor suppressor genes are going to have a much greater.
chance of not putting the brakes on that cancer because remember everybody has cancer everybody has this issue inside of a cell at any given time that's damaging the replication rate in the replication rate starts to go crazy the cell starts to replicate that is cancer but our immune system that is supposed to recognize that and kill it and we never get a diagnosis of cancer that's what's taking place constantly in everybody even if they don't have a cancer diagnosis.
What's helping that immune system recognize that cell that's in rapid replication is that tumor suppressor system and I say system because it's there's hundreds of genes that are involved in the tumor suppressor rapid replication cycle of any given cell so if I have defects in certain sets of groupings families of those genes I'm going to have an increased.
risk of cancer development and getting out of control and be getting a diagnosis of cancer when that does happen so we do want to look at those tumor suppressor genes as well as detox genes as well as dietary genes as God health genes and all the things that we look at when we look at your genetics those are all very important what common question that we get when we look at genes is how early should I look at genes should we start looking at.
My kids genes they're only 11 years old should we look at their genes by belief is the earlier that we can look at someone's genetic predisposition without scary them but we can look and say wow your son has the same pond one defects that you do that's a genetic family that.
Pond one pathway is responsible for many things but one thing it's responsible for is detoxing heavy metals and pesticides and chemicals and vaccinations so if you knew that you're 11 year old had a lot of defects on that pathway you could make lifestyle changes like wow we're not going to do vaccines on him we are not going to we are going to be very careful with additives flavorings colorings we're going to not spray
pesticides and insecticides on our lawn we are going to use only natural bug killers in our house everybody should be doing those things maybe every all already but knowing your genetics can kind of give you a motivational push to do to make certain environmental changes around you that could help prevent disease in the future and I think that's invaluable.
So it's not about oh my gosh you have the bronchotugin defect you're going to get cancer it's oh my gosh you have the bronchotugin defect you have to be more careful with your environment than someone who doesn't have the bronchotugin defect that's what it's looking at gives you motivational push to do the right thing so it's not just tumor suppressor genes when we look at the folate pathway the pathoid pathway the transulferation.
pathway and you know all the other iron pathways copper pathways it gives us a big broad picture of things that you can change maybe a supplement that would be really good for it maybe a supplement that you really should stay away from that can that can help you live not just cancer free but more disease free in the future know how to where you have weaknesses.
And where you have strengths it's just like doing a personality profile at your job here's your strength finder profile here's really where your strengths are here's where your weaknesses are maybe we need to strengthen those weaknesses or shore those up so that it doesn't cripple you in your job performance it's the same thing with your genetics here's your strengths here's your weaknesses you got serious weaknesses on these detox pathways.
We want to support those by really you should be on milk this or this product on a regular basis couple times a week for your life and that's going to really help prevent toxic exposure so that's the way to look at your genes.
In a healthy state and certainly in a disease state where do we need to support things to help things move a little better that's really what we call personalized medicine and I think.
It can't get much more personalized than that we don't want to just look at somebody in a disease state and try to fix them we want to look at why they're in that state and even from a functional medicine standpoint we used to do testing to see oh this person's got mercury toxicity that's why they have the symptoms so we're going to detox the mercury isn't it even a little bit deeper to see.
Wow, why do they have mercury toxicity well they're exposed to the vaccines or they had mercury fillings of their mouth well yes but going a little bit deeper looking at the genes they have all these pan one defects that's why they can't get rid of mercury so if we support that pan one pathway also knowing that there's a whole lot of things that are environment that you can't stay away from even if you try.
You could at least have a better chance in your body to get rid of those things when you're exposed to it and that's where genetics really give us a shining example.
So make sure you go to our website and watch these videos I mean it is going to be a requirement and my staff is trained now before your genetic review you've got to start watching some of these videos okay so.
It's really important because I know doing over 500 genetic reviews in the last few years it's very frustrating since I did make some of these videos I hear some I think on this page here there's I have so many videos I may have about 300 videos but here on this page the genetic slip testing I have some very generalized videos.
What how to order your 23 me what is a step what are a step basics what are what's the MTHFR gene that everybody talks about and so this really helps you understand some of the basic things and even if you don't want to nerd out on these things it's a lot easier to go over somebody's genetics when they spend a little bit of time understanding the terminology so that when we do.
Go over it. It's not like a deer in the headlights because I don't know what's is a new language and it's it's difficult to understand sometimes the more you can understand about your health the greater control you're going to have over it and the better results you're going to get okay so some questions that came in one question was what's your opinion on the supplement Torin Torin is an amino acid.
This person says I read that people at a vegetarian diet should use this Torin in order to help the detox pathways in the body so put on the slide of different things that Torin is found in Torin is considered a non essential amino acid.
So amino acids are categorized as essential and non essential so amino acids that are essential means that you need to get them in your diet because your body can't make them.
Non essential amino acids means that your body can make them from other amino acids and from other proteins.
So Torin is considered a non essential amino acid some people have a more difficult time making certain amino acids so that can be a problem and certain animals I don't have a difficult time making Torin like cats have to get Torin through their diet humans they should be able to make Torin normally through other amino acids.
That they consume but if you are a vegan especially and you're not eating any of these things you're not getting Torin in your diet now these are just the most common sources of Torin if you're eating eggs but you're not eating dairy and meat you're getting plenty of Torin Torin has good and bad things just like everything else it's all about balance remember there's no such thing as a good thing and a bad thing generally it's about balance when we're talking to them.
It's about specific nutrients that your body needs the good about Torin is Torin helps with muscle contraction Torin helps with detoxification because it aids a phosphatidol calling and production of bile so it does help with the detoxification phase three detox in your liver.
The bad about Torin is that Torin is a stimulant it's a stimulant to your cardio muscles it's also used as a neurotransmitter in your brain it's a stimulatory neurotransmitter that we've talked a lot about stimulatory neurotransmitters when we spoke about glutamate so glutamate is also a stimulatory neurotransmitter.
Torin is used probably the most common source of Torin that you see is in energy drinks so like red bull and those energy drinks have a lot of Torin because Torin is an excitatory neurotransmitter so it just like turns your brain on that's what helps wake you up right so when you drink shoot out a red bull you got caffeine in it and you have Torin in it which is highly stimulatory to your brain
well the danger of stimulatory neurotransmitters to your brain is you literally fry out those pathways
and you can severely damage your brain and increase Alzheimer's risks so I'm not a fan of supplemented Torin as a supplement
you could go to your local health food store or go on Amazon and search for Torin and you'll have a whole bunch
of supplements that are you know 100 milligrams of Torin and 100 milligrams they come in because I've never sold them
I'm not a fan of that you the issues other than brain issues which is bad enough as you could have heart issues with it
I remember one time they were giving samples of an energy drink this is the first time energy
drinks are out this is probably I don't know 10 years ago in a local bowl and I took one of these energy
drinks it was literally a half an ounce a little teeny little glasses that they were little cups like
communion cups that they were giving it it and I sampled it and my heart rate went like through the
roof for about 20 minutes I have a sensitivity to read obviously but so I've never had one of those
energy drinks except for that half an ounce that I consumed that one day because I feel like my
heart wasn't going to explode it's highly it's a strong strong stimulant and you have to be careful with
those with that I'd much rather have you get the majority of your amino acids through your food or
through a plant-based protein like the one we have on our store other questions that came in
what causes capillary fragility he manjomas that's when you get bruised and such does histamine
intolerance contribute to this well good question because histamine excess histamine does cause
it increase capillary fragility so excess histamine people that have issues with their
HNMT gene that's the gene that makes the DAO enzyme in the tissue to get rid of histamine in the tissue
people that have a lot of defects on their HNMT genes have a increase problem with histamine levels in
their body and more highly reactive to bug bites and skin rashes and skin reactions and sinus issues
and things like that all the issues of high histamine levels and they can have increased capillary
fragility so yes that's a piece there's a whole bunch other pieces of capillary fragility but
that is just that is another one how do you choose a good coconut oil does it should it be organic extra
virgin cold pressed unrefined what does the process matter yes it's very difficult to that's the same
problem that we haven't choosing just about any food out there I would say I would pick organic first
so I know there's other people and say oh you should only get coconut oil that's in a dark jar
because coconut oil is stable in a in a clear plastic jar yes that is true it's but it also depends
on how long it's been on the shelf personally we get our coconut oil at Costco it's organic in Costco
flies through their merchandise so it's never sitting on the shelf and then we keep it at a dark
cupboard so it isn't exposed to sunlight true rife has new updates with new frequent with new
frequency delivery systems in their hyperdrive et cetera should we update our programs yes I think
that you should update your true rife programs about every three to six months however that's really
only if you're using other programs than the ones that we made for you when you update your true
rife programs it will not change the programs that we made for you it will change if they made any
changes like made any changes to other programs and that's a good thing because he's updated and
tweaking different frequencies and different programs are adding programs so if you're not ever
using any other programs than the ones that we created you there is no ever reason for you to update
your your true rife program personally my rife at home I have it updated for years because I'm only
running the programs that I've created many of our patients are only running the programs that I've
created for them so there's really no need for them to update their programs if you're frequently
using other programs in your rife system which we encourage you to do so then about every three to
six months you're going to want to update the frequencies and it to update the frequencies I don't have
rife on this computer that I'm on right now so I can't show you but you literally open up any program
your rife the computer we're talking about the computer that your rife is on so the computer that
you got from our office has to be connected to the internet to do this you cannot update the rife
program if it's not connected to the internet because it's updated through the internet so if you're
connected to the internet you open up the computer you go to any rife program and you'll see on the top
tab bar update frequencies you click on that and let it go through its sequence you might have to
hit yes a couple times and it'll update it takes about five minutes and it's all updated that's how simple
it is concerning the secrets machine can we do repeating programs for two to three sessions of
one through ten yes you can you can't overdo those programs you could do multiple sessions
a day and for those who don't know what the secrets is we have some people that have a home secrets
at home this person does it's a wonderful low-frequency PEMF machine that is running specific
frequency similar to the rife machine through a different mechanism it's I love the secrets
machine it's fantastic so it's a great tool to be doing at a regular basis daily basis
personally whatever I go with the secrets machine has my staff I fall asleep so it's very
relaxing to me and it's a great machine so you can't really overdo it with your programs
all right so I'm going to open you up to questions and unmute everybody so if anybody has
any questions no is the time to speak up because this is damn I went to the store and right now
all the summer produce is out and really really relatively cheap organic ones is it okay to buy
in bulk and cut it all up and freeze it in freezer bags and does the freezer bag speak and
to the plastic leak into the food no I don't think it does the plastic plastic has is dangerous because
plastics end up causing issues with estrogens in our body and can stimulate bad estrogen production
in our body and lead to cancer especially so plastics have done a big fan of but really plastics
give off that product into the food when it's heated so if you're not putting hot food in the freezer
bags you're putting peppers in a freezer bag and stick it in the freezer you're really going around
very little plastic exposure there are some people that would say if you really what no plastic exposure
put in the glass they could put it in the freezer I don't know how you know you'd have to get some
sort of Pyrex freezer proof container to do that and if you really want to be perfect that that
probably would be the perfect thing to do we put our vegetables we have a big guarded drop-up
peppers by the way did it freeze your bags it did that I don't see any bigger harm
any other questions um this is Sharon when I got evaluated um it's like based on some of the
items that you test for you didn't you were not able to determine my cause of cancer
and does that mean you'll never be able to or um no uh if you were to be back here we could test you
again it might that might show up um we've even had people as we test them another time another thing
comes up remember like I've always said everybody has multiple causes of their cancer there's
multiple layers to to um our issues that we have um so it's so let's say a person comes up as
passed aside the cause of the cancer but there's probably I mean always stress is a piece of it
so there's always emotional pieces of the cause of our cancer but there's also causes of
why my immune system didn't kill this when it started growing which could be a genetic piece
tumor suppressor genes that I mentioned earlier on this call can be um other issues
tobacco toxins that are suppressed in my immune system or something that's affecting my
my uh sympathetic parasympathetic response it just goes on and on and on the the layers of
pieces that are causes um the reason why some people you know the only person that we can't find
the the specific cause is that it's it's not really one specific cause it's just a conglomeration
of a bunch of different things so it's like your body would it tell us the one thing because
it's it's almost like your body saying uh that's not important that it's it's it's too complex
it's it that's so just move on and figure out how you're going to correct this so I wouldn't say it's um
it's always it's it's always going to come up but there's a chance let's say you came back to
the office tomorrow we test you that's something would come up it has every as any as everybody
watched a lot of these genetic videos or is this new is this new information to you
I watched the sniff one before my this one right here or what's a step
the one that you had just explained the whole background okay and this is damn I watched the ones
that um pertained to the supplement you put this on uh huh you put me on how much those
it plus the sniff ones I started with the basics and then went to those with my supplement
but this hour and six minute one is what I created I don't know it was maybe a couple years ago
be going through a genetic profile and now the report is about two times or more longer than this one
is as we're constantly updating the software and pulling more data from the 23 me into this um so uh
but this really gives you a real good idea how we go through it um I mean literally
it takes a good hour or so for us to go through this uh through your data prior to us getting on the
phone with you uh and making recommendations and then it takes time to put those together afterwards
so it's it's a good several hours worth of work on our part to do that so it's just easier if you have
kind of done a little bit of homework so you're not asking questions that you have been answered
multiple times on these videos so it just helps you um again it empowers you and that's what
we're trying to do is give you that um that information say that you because I think a big part of
any disease is fear and that's I think with the more information that you have uh that can help
dispel some of that and uh that's that's one of our purposes here so uh and uh uh so make sure you
you take a peek at some of those. Dr. Conner's this is crystal and I have a question uh you had said
when I was in there um about my genetic testing that um at least some of the genetics defects that I
have might possibly be passed down to my children. If they would like to take a 23 in me test is there
someplace they can go to um you know have this into them I mean do you guys do that for someone who
is patient? Uh yeah we do so if um so if somebody calls us up off out of the blue they don't know us
from Hoot but they maybe saw one of my videos on YouTube or something like that and they
uh this is this is really common so we get people that contact us and say oh my gosh I saw one of
Dr. Conner's videos and I did my 23 in me a year and a half ago and my doctor read it and gave me a
one-page sheet of the answers and uh it didn't help me at all and and his videos talk about a 60-page
report that you guys go through I know how do I get that because again not to knock other doctors
out there but if you don't understand how to read your genetics you're just looking at a few genes
and then making a physical assessment on a patient it's it's just silly some of the recommendations
that we hear so um you want to take as big a step back as possible and look at as many genes as
possible to get a bigger picture as possible to help that patient the best way possible
and if you don't do that you're you're missing a lot so if that if a person calls it's out of the blue
there is a process that they have to go through we have to do a case review because we want to get to know
that person and then uh we go do a genetic review with them which is over a zoom call all of them are
done over zoom calls and we do the same thing is what we do what we're doing for you um but there's a
greater fee for it so our patients that are that have family members that want to do this
they have a discounted fee so we have what's called a family fee and Jed or one of the girls can
explain that to you which is literally half price so um it's cost you a few hundred dollars to go
through that for your family members and about half we'll do it for all your family members
for half price yes that's exactly right all right so um we try and i just think it's
the bar is done and we need to get Alexander's done Heather out of get hers done so should
have yeah so you it's just invaluable to go through this now understand if it's an 11 year old
oh wait we're going to go over that 11 year old boy's genes if we're preparing it now we'll have
it your old boy but um it's uh uh it could be invaluable for kids and for family members so we really
want to um uh we really want to make that available okay thank you all around all right any other
questions before we sign off for tonight um doctor kind of this is patty ross i do have a question
about um how young um like what is the well the biggest thing is is the ability to get a sample
so as soon as you can get the child to be able to spit in the bottle that's right okay so you have
to they have to be of an age and understanding that they're going to that they're going to be able
to spit in the thing you know you could collect a sample no you could certainly purchase a 23
and be kicked and then try it and then sit it in and if they don't get enough saliva they will
notify you and they will send you another kit to collect more than saliva so you can try it again
and if it doesn't work again they'll send you another kit and then you can just save it for another
to tell you like have turn it off live also a note that is that um um 23 and uh me uh people have
this question all the time i don't want 23 and me to see to have my genetic data because they could
sell it and my comment is how does 23 and me know it's your genetic data the only way they know it
is because you gave them your name okay so if you feel and i don't tell 23 me i'm telling you this
because they probably get mad at me but if you felt like that that you don't want to let anybody
else to know your genetic data because you plan on committing a horrible crime you know the year
and you want them to find out it was you then that was a good reason but let's pretend you don't want
anybody to find out your genetic data a fictitious name so just use a fictitious name and
and create a new email because your email is going to be the your user name and then you create a
password with 23 and me so just use if you don't want them to have your child's data that you're
afraid they're going to sell it now there's new laws that are preventing them from doing that like
they used to a few years ago but if you still don't trust them which maybe you don't um just write
out a different name you have to tell us what that name is it will go it is your name in our software
but understand our software is our software nobody else can be able to see it so um and your data is
protected through the PMA so nobody can even request your information it um so even if even if
some governmental agency called us or said does the letter requested all your information for some reason
be through the pastoral medical association that's one of the great things about being a part of it
is that all your records are sealed uh i don't care who they are they don't get your records
and nobody's going to see your genetic stuff but us so um it's all safe with us
i can't see you both times oh right no i can't see you both times you know so i did not agree
oh we okay any other questions the red button on it we're about 10 seconds and then
okay all right so we're gonna close it up for tonight and um remember to send your zoom call
questions into counters clinic at gmail.com and write a little uh headed in um info bar that it is a
zoom call question so that we see that and we will be able to get your call question on our slide and
be able to answer those hopefully as best they know how uh and we'll see you guys next week
i have to call my two. All right, bye bye.